＜世界大会
は）2017年の
は）世界で一番強い人を決める大会の優勝者
は）誰かご存じでしょうか
は）世界の強者を倒し
は）世界のトップに君臨した人はこの人です
は）どうぞ
は）あこんばんわぁ
は）今んとこ世界チャンピオンでしょ
辻）今ん所っす来年迄は世界チャンピオン
は）現段階での世界チャンピオン辻村君で～す
/ ｷﾞｭｳｨｰﾝ \
は）おーっとここで
は）世界一になる前からちょっと知ってたもんね
辻）そうですね
は）ちょいちょい一緒に静岡で遊戯王してて
は）店舗代表
は）静岡の代表決めるやつとかも一緒にいたりして
は）俺が負けて
あぁやべぇ勝ったなぁ
は）とか思って見てて
は）国内予選も勝ってって
は）で世界大会行ってきますみたいな事言って
は）一回戦勝ちっすわみたいな
辻）そうLINEしてて
辻）決勝戦の動画あったじゃないですか
は）あったあった
辻）パソコンのスクショか何か見せててクソ笑われてるっていうｗ
は）そうそうｗめっちゃ見てた
は)俺たち両方静岡っていうね
は)もう知らぬ間に気づけば世界一になってたみたいな
は)僕も教わりながら実はでデュエルやってたんですけども
は)検証して行きたいと思います
は）出た出たwww
は）いやほんと世界一強いんでなんだろう
運とかっていうか、結局ここもね
は）あるんすよ
辻）まあかなり…うーんかなr…
は）世界チャンピオンに僕が一回でも勝てたらそこで検証終了でございます
は）では1回戦目です!
は）お願いします
辻）お願いします
辻）じゃあ先行で
は）はい
は）はい！大丈夫です
辻）ｗｗｗ
は）うーーーーーーーーーーーーん…
は）ウウェアアアアーーーー！
は）スタンバイ！メイン！
（トントン）
は）ありざぁした…
（スゥーーーーー）
（フゥーーーーーーー）
は）まぁ…1回目でチャンピオンの実力を知りつつ…
は）その後 どう戦っていくかポイントです
は・辻）最初はぐっ！！じゃんけんポイ！
は・辻）あいこでしょ！
あいこでしょ！
んーしょ！
しょ！
は）よっしゃ！
は）うわぁ…
は）はいオッケーです…
は）んーー…
辻）終わり！
は）ドローフェーズ！
は）ドロー！
は）スタンバイ
は）スリーフェイス…
は）WIN！
辻）ふーーー…
辻）負けたんだけど…
辻）ｗｗｗ